well I the climate change deal reached
in Paris yesterday has been described as
historic after two weeks of intense
negotiations close to 200 countries
agreed to the pack which has a legally
binding core 1 join now by the Virgin
Group handle philanthropist sir richard
branson he's on necker island hello
there sir richard and i've often
wondered i'm sure you have um if this
deal doesn't work is your own beloved
necker island at risk from rising sea
levels yes I think all all islands would
be a tremendous risk from rising sea
levels and I think many many cities in
the world as well but what happened in
Paris as you say was historic and you
know that nearly 200 countries got
together and decided to do the right
thing by by that by the public on a
throughout throughout the world and say
we do not want the temperature to rise
above one and a half degrees absolute
maximum two degrees and I think with
that clear signal then it's up to
business leaders worldwide to rally
around and and you know help make sure
that that becomes reality and I think it
I think it can be a reality interesting
what you say they're sharing about
business leaders is that more so than
the politicians I mean is that because
the business leaders have their hands on
the levers of industry and they're
likely an actual fact to be a around a
lot longer than some of the politicians
well I think governments need to set the
set the rules they need to make sure for
instance that clean energy the taxes on
clean energy are a lot less than the
taxes on dirty energy so they need to
set the ground rules to make sure that
there is a clean energy revolution and
then business leaders need to come up
with break the breakthrough technologies
to make this happen but you know about
working with governments so for instance
the gates and myself and a few other
people got together and to set up
something called the breakthrough
coalition and and we've got like minded
people who want to
invest in breakthrough technologies but
we're also working with governments
who've also agreed to put money into
breakthrough technologies as well so I
think it you know I think it can be it
can be a combined attack and do you
think they've got I mean this is the key
question arising one of them certainly
from the summit do you think they've got
the balance right between the developed
world those that in many cases can
afford to make these changes and the
developing world those that say you
can't pull the drawbridge up on us if
you want us to go clean and green we
need some cash yeah I think I think by
and large they did get the balance right
I mean it was the you know incredibly
difficult negotiation where you had to
get every single country to sign off in
it and and and every single country did
sign off in it and including countries
where it patently wasn't in their
interest to sign off on it like Saudi
Arabia and you know because you know
what's what's going to happen is that
oil and coal will have to stay in the
ground if we're going to be carbon
neutral by 2050 and and that those
countries that are you know solely led
by exporting oil and coal are going to
have to move their move their countries
forward into new areas quite quickly and
and so and you know say wait it was
remarkable and I think open you know I
mean what we've got to do is every year
between now and 2050 we've got to move
our country's forward by about three
percent per year and in you know
replacing dirty energy with clean energy
and and and I think that is possible and
I think it will also have the benefit
for the public in the shorter term of
keeping the price of dirty fuels lower
which which will actually help and you
know help to help with the economy
generally if you've got more clean
energy being produced than demand for
energy then then I think will benefit
from low energy prices maybe
forever from now and so Richard I just
want to relate this to another very live
debate which I know you have a key
interesting it is of course the debates
in the United Kingdom about how we
expand airport capacity and in
particular whether there will be a third
runway at Heathrow Airport as you know a
decision delayed on that one but I know
you support it and people will say and
I'm sure you've heard it before Sir
Richard then how do you square your
passionate environmental credentials
with them the call for another runway at
heathrow and it is always a balancing
act in life and I mean what we you know
we've got four organizations that are
working on on the environmental side so
we have the carbon war room that is
trying to work with industries try to
reduce their carbon output we've got the
B team which is you know lobbying
governments and what you know we were we
were all in Paris trying to make sure
that these climate talks got done we've
got the breakthrough Energy Coalition
that's trying to come up with new new
new breakthrough technologies and one of
the breakthrough technologies we're
trying to come up with is clean clean
jet aviation fuels which and I you know
which I think will happen in the
not-too-distant future now with with
with a big enough pushing it and so so
the idea the ideal for Great Britain is
and you know it definitely needs a new
runway it needed a new runway actually I
think it needed to new runways about 25
years ago it's holding Great Britain
back and and but you know the the
government need to set very clear rules
that to say that the planes that are
that the planes had operate there must
be as environmentally friendly as
possible as fast as possible and it's
going to take 20 years to build the new
runway so by then I think you know plate
planes will be palpably quarter and
probably more environmentally friendly
than they are asked a ok so Richard
great talking to you thank you very much
indeed for your thoughts on that he
throw that under the climate change deal
sir richard branson there